this is the port district of Tel Aviv
it's a popular shopping area and the
perfect place to meet up with drawer
sharone a former member of the Air Force
and now the founder of consumer physics
the company raised 2.7 million dollars
via a huge Kickstarter campaign so that
it could produce a device called the
saya which may soon change the way we
shop for groceries when you think about
it how do you make your selection today
grab it and feel the out fur that is so
it's good yeah you know you might want
to have some scientific back into what
you're doing
right the saya replaces your grandmother
squeeze test sorry grandma to tell you
the best cucumber or tomato to pick in
an instant it displays the food's
calorie fat and sugar content it's the
quickest way to finding the perfect
potato that's cool it's really when you
can actually bring yourself everybody's
like some Star Trek the spectrometer
usually looks like this it's a big old
hunk a scientific gear that can peer
into things and determine their
properties rather incredibly this IO
shrinks much of the same technology down
onto a chip it zaps an object with
near-infrared light stirs up its
molecules and tells a story about the
object as people go around zapping
things with this IO the objects get put
into a database this then becomes a
giant log of all the materials in our
world that sounds all well and good but
how would the seal fare against one of
mankind's most mysterious creations this
is the cheese test good ol American
Velveeta labels the labels t90 here
three others it's almost flat out that's
the fat percentage of the way 323 and
you're 25 the size value should go well
beyond kumquats and industrialize cheese
it can help farmers decide when to
harvest their crops it can detect
watered-down fuel at Shady gas stations
and it can tell real medicine for fake
pills when you think of health care
actually it's not about what you're
buying is actually tracking your
well-being over time and instead of
sending stuff to the lab you'll actually
be able to measure it on yourself drawer
even sees a future for this device in
your bathroom you can measure teeth you
can measure saliva can measure hair you
can measure urine imagine the other
thing so I mean there's there's a ton of
stuff and people are coming up that
they're going to use it for technical
trials I'm gonna take my smartphone into
the toilet
well it'll be probably inside your
toilet away all right yeah that makes
sense
you
you
you